la beauté d'abord une chose qui passe
est une chose sur laquelle on nous
apprend beaucoup à compter enfin on nous
apprend aussi qu'on la jette à un
certain moment donnner la beauté parce
qu'elle passe parce qu'elle est plus
égale à elle-même la célébrité elle est
du au plus grand des hasards et à
l'appui euh des hommes je crois que euh
on doit les actrices sont dépendantes
comme comme toutes les autres de du
règne des hommes moi à partir du moment
où je me rends compte et où je le dis je
deviens quelqu'un de très antipathique
pour les hommes ces discours de Delphin
serig et puis d'autres bien avant
pratiquement depuis le début de
l'humanité ne sont pas reliés à chaque
fois c'est recouvert chaque lutte chaque
avancée chaque prise de conscience est
recouvert par bah la pensée dominante et
donc réoublier c'est dingue des
compositrices des des des peintteresses
des autrices et cetera elles sont
effacées
quoi